okay.
Let's go next to our caller from the nine
one six area code.
Who's calling today from nine one six.
Hey, David, this is Ronald calling from Sacramento.
Hey, Ronald, what's going on?
Hey, uh, yeah, just two quick questions.
Love the show.
Uh, just wanted to ask, um, from 1969 to 1993,
aside from four years of Jimmy Carter, from
77 81, uh, it was all Republican.
Do you think there's any chance of the left
getting that same kind of run in today's type
of politics?
Honestly, no.
I mean, the reason that I would say no is
that there are a bunch of structural elements
that favor the Republican Party.
We've talked about the fact that Gee, um,
uh, gerrymandering makes it so that at the
national level, democrats need more than half
of the votes to secure half of the districts
in an electoral college presidential election.
It's a little different, but similar logic
applies.
The fact that conservatives tend to live more
in rural areas and, uh, left wingers in urban
areas also favors in the map.
Um, Republicans, voter suppression and fewer
people voting favors.
Republicans, Trump now has put two people
on the Supreme Court who are going to be influencing
the court for decades, including in election
law related areas, which favors Republicans.
So I see it as very unlikely that Democrats
will have the run that Republicans had unless
there is some kind of drastic change or a
backfire effect to the Trump presidency that's
bigger than what we're seeing.
I don't see it as very likely.
Yeah, I agree.
And I thought I was just being a pessimist,
but like I'm originally from La and I, the
amount of like make America great again.
Hats I've seen in like areas like the inland
empire and a, you know, like even the, um,
like the, like Orange County.
Like every time Trump writes off California,
I'm like, Eh, we, there are plenty of people
out here rooting for you.
They just, they just happen to be white and
from California.
But
yeah, I mean that's, that it's like the reverse
of the Texas thing.
I mean, California is a very blue state and
Texas is often considered a very red state,
although less so recently.
But what you've got to understand is there's
still millions of voters in California who
loved Trump.
And if it weren't for those coastal cities,
Trump could win.
And in Texas, there's also millions of voters
who, who do not like Republicans and they're
mostly congregated in cities.
Even though in raw numbers, Democrats still
have a big lead in California and Republicans
in Texas.
These are not like immutable forever things
and immigration as far from with from other
states I'm talking about as well as demographic
changes can really change these things over
like a 10 to 15 year period.
Yeah.
And um, and I appreciate you sound off on
that cause I've like looked all around for
the answer to this question.
And you know, that's the first time I've heard
like something that's really coherent.
And lastly, quick question I want to ask you
is even though it's being treated like, like
a bathroom fight in high school, I think the
reparations conversation is, is important
just because of the country's history.
But do you think, uh, cause the big thing
I've heard from a lot of people is the like
the, the, the example of like America will
give Israel 4 billion in military support
every year.
And you know, it only took America three years
and to basically a wreck Israel after like
three years after the Holocaust.
Do you think that's a good example for why
black Americans deserve reparations and why?
Like the numbers should be higher?
No, I've never heard that.
And it doesn't sound like a good analogy.
It sounds like a losing argument to me.
I've never heard that before.
I'd have to think about it more, but my instinct
is that sounds weird.
I don't really get it.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Well yeah.
Uh, I appreciate your, your answers and uh,
thanks so much for picking up.
All right, I appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from you.
Um, okay.
That is all the time I have today.
Sorry to everybody.
I didn't get to hope everybody has a good
4th of July holiday.
We will take calls again, live streams upcoming
on youtube and lots of other great stuff.
Quick break, very important audience questions
that I will be answering after this.
Very short break.